welcome back all right we are
celebrating pasta week all week long
that's why we call it pasta week
and what better way to pay homage to the
humble noodle than a cookbook club pick
with my culinary partner in crime
today's pick comes from the great hedy
mckinnon
and my culinary partner in crime is the
one and only chef velour valdez
bye everyone
so today what we're doing is a spicy
sesame tantanmen ramen
from hedy mckinnon's to asia with love i
love that cookbook all the recipes in
this book to asia with love are actually
vegetarian the recipe we're making today
is actually vegan so what you have there
is some sesame oil with some ginger and
garlic that's been sauteing and then
we're gonna throw in our crumbled firm
tofu
into that mixture and it just it just
smells so good so
we've mixed everything in and then drew
to your side you're gonna have mirin
which is a japanese
rice wine than rice wine cooking wine
and then we're going to do a little bit
of tamari as well
and then we're going to throw in the
miso paste also i love miso paste so
drew as soon as you have that mixed in
really nicely okay nice and crumbled
um you're just gonna let it go actually
and stop mixing it and what that's gonna
do is basically develop this like nice
crispy crust on the tofu as it cooks so
while that's cooking i'm at a seven
we're gonna make uh the sauce or the
broth basically so in the bowl
we're gonna whisk up a little in the
bowl you have some tahini so we're going
to put a little bit more of the tamari
and that's going to give you again like
that deep savoriness
lovely and then to break up a little bit
of the the creaminess you're going to
have a little bit of the rice wine
vinegar
in that bowl oh that's starting to look
really nice
and then we have some chili oil so as
soon as you're all mixed into we're
going to walk over to the big pot over
here
and in this pot we have some vegetable
stock
and
some soy milk so that's again the
creaminess you're just building that in
if you don't want to do soy milk you can
absolutely substitute for any
any of your favorite nut milks basically
and you're going to whisk that in drew
i'm going to check my
so you can see
i'm getting like
all this texture you have a little bit
of crispy crunchy and then the softness
too and that's exactly where you want it
all right i'm gonna pop that off and
then drew i think we're ready to
assemble
our ramen bowl right
all right so what hedy says is basically
cook your favorite ramen noodle
according to the package uh instructions
and then in the last 30 seconds
into the water throw your vegetables so
here we have some leafy greens and some
bean sprouts so you really just want to
shock the raw off of it but you still
want it to be crunchy
nice and fresh so shall we shall we
assemble
yes let's do it all right so you have
your cooked ramen noodles cooked
a little bit of greens
i know you love your bean sprouts too
right i love bean sprouts
i love
crunch i need texture
um and then we've got some speaking of
texture some sweet corn as well i love
that touch um so that's gonna be like a
real nice like pop of freshness because
she likes to keep the kernels raw
and then your tofu must we forgot
last we forgot
so i'm pouring my nice broth over here
treating myself to something real
special and then we got your garnish we
got some sesame seeds toasted sesame
seeds
a little bit of scallions this is
szechuan chili and then it's more
chili crisp basically
we did say it was going to be hot
and there you have it it's hedy
mckinnon's spicy sesame tantan men ramen
i love it it's so beautiful
cheers
i love you so much
thank you for bringing this to the table
oh my god fuller that's so good it just
made me weaker than the knees
that is so
so good like a man i need to i need to
go in
a man hasn't made me weaken the knees
like this ramen house i need to date
this ramen thank you hedy
you can uh pick up a copy of our
recommended cookbook or get the full
recipe at the website
thedrewberrymoreshow.com
and thank you pillar for bringing this
pic
to
the week
and we
will be right back
[Music]
you